wir sind heute nach graz gefahren das
liegt in österreich und zwar wo genau
matthias im süden österreichs im süden
österreichs an der grenze zu slowenien
und ja genau
wir wollen wissen was besonders ist an
dieser stadt an der region an den
menschen hier deswegen fragen wir jetzt
hier in graz los geht's
was macht ganz besonders was macht
gerade besonders in graz ist insofern
besonders dass gerade einfach
canis trotzdem aber wunderschön sind die
innenstadt ist echt also ich war jetzt
für europa unterwegs und es ist nicht
wirklich vergleichbar mit vielen anderen
städten einfach immer das gibt schon
sehr schöner städte aber es ist
einzigartig einfach die dachlandschaft
wenn es jetzt wirklich am schloss warum
bist du schaust darüber wie es ist
wunderschön die leitern finde die recht
freundliche mann das liegt daran dass
man darüber haben ist in gewisser weise
aber ich finde einfach gerade recht auch
von der stadt von und es trifft heute
alles aufeinander ist es gibt von jeder
sorte aber leid und das ist echt schön
also vielfältig auf jeden fall ist
einfach stark belebt und es ist immer
was los und gerade für studenten
du bist du bist du und so machen
konturen cards oder man wird drei tage
ja was macht ganz besonders wir wollen
schon völlig schwarz hat wirklich sehr
imponiert schmerzlich zur weihnachtszeit
und so ist auch dass man wieder aber
irgendwie anders
das an die menschen anders wie in wien
auf der kommode und viel zumindest
anders
ich kann nicht sagen warum mit wirklich
mehr noch graz nach wien wo er wohnt das
passierte was ihre groupies mit in
winzer flörke und durch bei uns gefunden
möglicherweise jährlich ja ganz genau
das so besonders ist die altstadt und
das spazierengehen kamen und ohne
irgendwie belästigt zu werden
hier ist es eigentlich eine
österreichische tradition oder eine
grazer tradition dass man tannenbäume
falsch rum aufhängt na ja sagt zum
ersten mal halt in graz gesehen also ich
glaube nicht dass das der tradition ist
schon cool aus schöneck weiters können
naja im vergleich zu deutschland gerade
hat eine altstadt was schon mal schön
oder
und ansonsten ist gerade sehr lebenswert
finde ich graz ist zwar die zweitgrößte
stadt von österreich aber finden dass
klar ist trotzdem sehr familiär und
heimelig ist weil wenn die stadt geht
kennt man immer irgendjemanden uns ja
als einfach schon noch ein paar leute
trifft der was man kennt und jonas ist
eine familiäre stadt werde ich sagen na
ja also warum ist die wahl auf gras kann
das sollte jetzt nicht hören eigentlich
ist es war ein psychologe das war die
wahl zwischen einer und fünf städte und
gerade hat sich schön angehört ich
kannte ja salzburg graz zeichnet sich
für mich vor allem durch die
gemütlichkeit aus was soll in graz gibt
es auch wenn das jetzt ein wenig zu sehr
viele parks fünf wunderschöne praxis und
das ist eine sehr gelassene stadt die
leute sind sehr offen und umgänglich
also wenn das oft anders wie in anderen
ich habe wenn man mal die überall gelebt
es schwer zu vergleichen
gerade noch besonders das ist einfach
die perfekte größe das nicht klein und
groß so groß wie nicht so klein wie
jetzt mal klagenfurt das war genau die
goldene mitte
kannst du irgendwie die grasnarbe
schreiben
die gerade zu einem besonderen charakter
ja ich finde gerade zu sagen sehr nett
sie sind auf jeden fall ausgeschlossen
dass die wiener ja also ich finde gratis
und sie haben nette und offene menschen
ja woher genau weiß tage später am
kasberg bezirk gaya und sagt die grazer
haben besonders oder will schon sagen
dass die grazer vergleich zu anderen
österreichischen städten recht
freundlich sind gegenüber trend und
alles mögliche ich wohne folge einen
grat ich werde also ich habe gerade mal
bist du okay du studierst arbeite gerade
für gut was ist welcher lieblingsplatz
in graz aber was man schon gesehen haben
das grazer schloss ihr recht geben
häufig muss was ihr unglück nicht
anschauen
ich fand das mausoleum echt schön das
ist er da hinten auf die straßen links
da ist neben graz atom ist ein
wunderschönes museum da ist der kaiser
wir sind jetzt liegen
das ist genau wie der kaiser ist dort
bekommen auf jeden fall
und gleich ein teil waffe ist die
wendeltreppe die doppelte distanz auf
jeden fall kleiner tipp der mit jetzt so
offensichtlich ist ja wieder schlossberg
oder sogar zum thema kunst und kultur
irgendwas graz es war ja irgendwo
hauptstadt ja auch irgendwie bemerkbar
machen aber so überhaupt irgendwie ein
schwerpunkt auf kunst und kultur neuen
kraft oder häufig schon als sind immer
irgendwelche kulturellen und
kunstprojekte fahren im sommer die erste
la strada als elf hinschauen dass sich
noch immer mit der kulturhauptstadt
identifizieren kann ja einen
lieblingsplatz
der burggarten ist wunderschön
das parkhaus im stadtpark bau garten das
ausschließen
das sind so meine lieblingsplätze oder
wenn man die mumbai machten spaziert ist
wasser das wird leider jetzt geflutet
ich würde sagen das ist mehr ging gerade
der ganze norden liegt das heißt
eigentlich wenn es schöner sich dass das
ein relativ schöne sich doch gerade und
das hat natürlich nicht das klassische
grab ist was anderes und das
rechtfertigt das okay für cool und wie
ist das macht die krater und irgendwo
anders in österreich
wir merken steirisch als sie ihm
ergebene aus salzburg und yvonne in wien
und wenn in graz finden ist haben die
leute so extrem freundlich und des
quellcodes ja hast du vielleicht
eigentlich ganz typischen wörter die
burgenländische oder oder so weiter sagt
irgendwas was man vielleicht gar nicht
kennt was man nicht kennt kann jetzt
sozusagen aber typisch bayerisch ist es
sicher dass wir das können und das nur
funktioniert sagt sie
wie geht es mit der sprache her
verstehst du alles klar oder
für mich muss mich schon ein bisschen
umgewöhnen und so einige worte haben wir
jetzt schon übernommen auch irgendwas
was machst des burgenländers vorne
sprache ist es ähnlich aus wienerischen
in love mit gewinnen
ganz ähnlich wie die aussteiger früh
spannend erst in unserem unterschied von
selecta 7 auf salzburger und grenze
österreich burgenländer und ein
unterschied ist das nicht so stark
glaube ich dir hast du bei uns denn
unter
jetzt wie wir hätten einen anderen
dialekt auf jeden fall widerspricht
sagen graz hat ehrlich ich bin
eigentlich aus der obersteiermark dass
ihr wahrscheinlich unserer mischung
obersteirische mischung
ja liebe leute das war's das war unser
letztes video in diesem jahr und wir
möchten die gelegenheit jetzt zum
jahresabschluss noch einmal nutzen um
uns bei allen von euch vor allem bei
unseren unterstützern zu bedanken
mittlerweile gibt es 740 personen die
uns jede woche mit einer kleinen spende
bei katrin unterstützen und das ist
wirklich der hammer wir sind ganz nah
dran
unser traum zu verwirklichen und easy
german wirklich zu unserem
ausschließlichen hart beruf zu machen wo
das freut uns total denn dank euch
müssen wir uns keine sorgen machen ihr
haltet uns den rücken frei damit wir uns
auf easy germany auf unsere videos aber
auch auf neue ideen konzentrieren können
wir möchten uns auch bei allen von euch
bedanken die wir in diesem jahr
persönlich kennenlernen durften wir
hatten viele schöne begegnungen mit euch
sei es weil ihr uns in eure schule
eingeladen habt oder zu unseren meetings
gekommen seid manche von euch haben uns
auch eine e mail geschrieben an unserem
videos teilgenommen oder ihr habt an
unserer easy german summer school
teilgenommen
all diese begegnungen bereichen und sehr
und machen uns sehr viel spaß und wir
hoffen sehr dass wir im nächsten jahr
noch viele schöne neue begegnungen mit
euch haben werden
eine kooperation die uns in diesem jahr
ganz besonders gefreut hat war die
zusammenarbeit mit jeremy er ist ein
amerikanischer software-entwickler der
hier in berlin lebt und er hat uns
interaktive übungen zu unseren videos
gebaut das heißt herr diejenigen von
euch die schon ein mitglied bei katrin
sind können jede woche diese
interaktiven übungen ausprobieren und
dadurch ihr deutsch verbessern
das hat uns sehr gefreut aber das ist
noch nicht alles
gemeinsam mit ihm arbeiten wir auch seit
einigen monaten an
einer sprach lernplattformen die wir
jetzt in den kommenden wochen bald
veröffentlicht werden und wir glauben
dass diese plattform euch helfen kann
noch schneller und vor allem
unterhaltsamer deutsch zu lernen und
freut euch schon mal darauf ja das war's
jetzt wir gehen jetzt silvester feiern
was man so macht hier in berlin heute
ist ja der 31
zwölfte der letzte tag des jahres wir
hoffen dass wir gut ins neue jahr
rutscht und wenn ihr lust habt zu diesem
video noch übungen zu machen werden ein
patch in abonniert easy german und
schaltet nächste woche wieder ein denn
nächste woche haben wir ein ganz
besonderes video für euch dass wir schon
sehr lange vorbereitet habe und dass
viele nützliche tipps enthält wie euer
deutsch noch verbessern könnte bis bald
bis zum nächsten jahr
guten rutsch